Hey guys, Pete here. Today's Game of
Thrones Season 8 video will look at the
big questions that come up after episode
4. I thought this episode was a strong
episode for character moments and it did
its job of moving us towards the end
game. I ranked it as my second favorite
episode of the season behind episode 2.
there were a lot of big moments, a lot of
nice callbacks but it leaves us with a
lot of questions and that's what I will
talk about today. real quick and update
on my last video if you watched my trailer
breakdown I drew attention to the
character who's wearing the hood when I
initially looked at that I thought he
was being brought out by the golden
company but some people commented that
he's walking away from them so I looked
a little bit closer and he is actually
passing the golden company and this
leads me to believe that it is Jaime
Lannister re-entering the city of King's
Landing. the clothing looks exactly the
same as what Jaime was wearing when he
came to Winterfell, it looks the same as
what he was wearing when he left so I
think this is actually Jaime's return.
but, today I've got 8 big questions
there's only two episodes of Game of
Thrones left so I imagine we're gonna
get the answers to most of these and
let's jump into it. Number eight is Rhaegal dead? this question popped up a lot
in the comments in my last video and I
see where people are coming from but yes
Rhaegal is dead. we have been trained as
viewers of Game of Thrones to question
the deaths of characters sometimes they
come back like the Hound where he was
left for dead but managed to pull
through
sometimes they straight come back like
John who was actually dead but revived
by magic. in the case of Rhaegal the
showrunners made specific mention of his
death and Dany losing him in the after
the episode and this time I believe them
I really don't think there's anything
going on there I think that he died and
that's the last we'll see of him. number
7 is Cleganebowl going to happen? since
we saw the Hound heading south I do
believe a showdown with his brother is
bound to happen at this point not sure
if it's gonna play out in the same way
that inspired all the hype around the
theory years ago but I would be really
surprised if we don't see Sandor step to
Gregor I think there's definitely a
chance that it may
come out feeling like a mercy killing
when it's all said and done but that
might just be wishful thinking on my
part. number six what's up with the
pregnancies? Cersei's pregnancy is
becoming mysterious and Daenerys getting pregnant with Jon's child seems less
likely as time passes Cersei has used
her pregnancy to her advantage with
Jaime, Tyrion, and Euron at this point. at
the same time if she is pregnant now and
Jaime is the father shouldn't she be too
far along to pass it off as Euron's? then
there's the obvious problem that she
doesn't appear to be far along or even
pregnant at all when we see her
something doesn't add up here and it's
hard to figure out what she's up to
many fans thought Daenerys would become
pregnant and that would be a way for
Jon and Daenerys to set aside their
problems and work together I think there
was some setup for this in season 7 but
so far in this season their intimate
relationship has ceased to exist so the
real question here is will anyone end up
pregnant at the end besides Gilly and
Sam? we're gonna have to wait and see
number five will Arya cross Cersei off
of her list?
we know Arya is heading south with the
hound and she only has two names left on
that list. i lean towards her not killing
Cersei if not for any other reason
than she already killed the night
king and as mentioned earlier I think
the Hound will probably kill the
mountain what does that leave for Arya
to do in the capital then well I think
there's plenty she could do to help Jon
and Daenerys defeat Cersei that doesn't
include her ending the current queen
with her own hands. I think it would be
cool to do something with her that ends
up transforming her changes her path
from the assassin mode she's been on for
so long but I'm trying to keep my
expectations in check when it comes to
Atya's story. I would love to see her go
in a different direction but I'm not
sure they're setting that up to this
point number 4 how will Jon react when
he finds out Sansa broke her promise to
keep his secret? this is a big question
and one I don't have an answer to Jon
should view this as the betrayal that it
is but since these two characters are
separated by geography for the time
being it's hard to say if he'll do
anything when he finds out I do expect
that he'll find out before
episode 5 ends but not sure if Sansa
will experience any immediate
repercussions John has the battle and
his relationship with Daenerys directly
in front of him and I think that
whatever happens between him and Sansa
will be related to the outcome of what
happens in King's Landing personally I
don't think it'll end up getting
completely glossed over though because
it's pretty serious I mean he told her
in confidence they were just all talking
about the importance of family and
sticking together and she turned around
and broke the promise number three why
did John not give ghost a proper goodbye?
after episode four concluded Twitter was
flooded with posts about the strange
goodbye between John and ghost like he
couldn't even spend a few seconds
patting his head and telling him he was
a good boy tell him that uncle Tommen
was going to take him up north where he
could run and hunt and have a good life
the answer to this question probably
won't satisfy you if you were one of
those people who lost faith in John a
little bit after the goodbye but the
director of the episode has explained
what's going on here in an interview
with Kim Renfro from insider David
Nutter explained that it all came down
to the way they shot the scene he says
that ghost wasn't right next to the
actors and so forth so there wasn't any
issues with green-screen or situations
where we're dealing with any kind of
rotoscoping when Renfro asked him
directly about if they did it this way
to simplify the filming process Nutr
answered simply with a yes so it is what
it is I guess but I can't help wondering
if Jon's sending ghosts away to the
north doesn't hint at his own fate there
are quite a few theories out there about
Jon going up north of Winterfell at the
end of the story so could he end up
following his direwolf when it's all
said and done number two will Daenerys
become the mad queen? the idea of Dany
story going in that direction isn't a
new idea this was a theory that book
readers came up with and debated long
before she made her way to Westeros
I've never been a fan of this idea but
after episode 4 it's hard to ignore the
setup that were seeing. in episode 4 we
saw Daenerys come to the realization at
the celebration that she's not loved by
the people like Jon is this leads to
them finally having a conversation where
she can't
convinced him to keep his parentage a
secret everything spirals from there
until at the end of the episode she has
lost a dragon, lost her closest friend in
Missandei, and lost the confidence in
her trusted advisor Varys. everything is
pointing her towards a well-deserved fit
of rage it would be hard to blame
Daenerys for burning down King's Landing
based on what we saw her experience in
this episode not to mention everything
she's experienced in her path to get
here but does that actually qualify as
madness for me by definition it doesn't
I mean madness implies severe mental
illness you don't think of a person who
is mad to be conflicted about the things
they're doing they've just lost it I
don't think that in this context that's
what people are actually saying about
Daenerys though I think they're talking
about her becoming the villain when they
say the mad queen. either way I think
there's more complexity to Danny's story
and that's why I've never thought she
would become an actual villain in simple
terms her conflict is rooted in that she
wants to make the world a better place
but the most effective tool she has is
her dragon for a long time this has led
me to believe that she'll have a choice
to make get what she wants through force
or sacrifice what she wants for the
greater good
my hope is that she'll make the choice
for the greater good because I think
that makes her story better but she
could go the other way which I suppose
would qualify as going the mad Queen
route I know in the book she has an
internal conflict like she worries about
becoming something like her father in
the show they may not bring that up as
much but I think there is something
under the surface that she's reluctant
to use force but at the same time there
is this idea of destiny they mentioned
it in the last episode I mean she
hatched dragons from a funeral pyre it
seems like you gotta run with that
whenever that happens but we'll have to
wait and see what goes down number one
is Jamie going back to Cersei? I saved
this one for last because I think it's
the most interesting one of course he is
going back to Cersei we saw him leave
Brienne and I do think he's the hooded
figure we see passing the golden company
in the trailer the real question I think
fans
if he's going back to her because he
loves her or going back to kill her
my initial thinking was that he probably
doesn't even know he's in love with
Brienne but probably feels conflicted
when the news reaches Winterfell about
your on attacking Daenerys I guess that
her telling him that she was pregnant
with his child would also play a part in
that when he said what he said to
Brienne and reminded me a lot of how
Tyrion was so cold with Shae when he
wanted her to leave King's Landing as in
he was saying what he thought would push
her away and that he didn't necessarily
believe it himself but in the same
interview I mentioned above the director
of episode 4 gives a different
explanation when asked if Jaime was
slipping back into that deep bond he has
with Cersei David Nutter confirmed it in
the process he's saying that his
intention isn't to go and kill her even
if it means losing his own life but that
he really is still under her spell and
when you think about it this does
actually make sense
Cersei is the only thing he's ever known
well I imagine there's a good chance
that he'll change his mind once he gets
there it's fascinating to know that this
is actually his motivation it's as if he
found something better with Brienne but
doesn't believe that he deserves it and
that makes his character way more
compelling to me when I think about it
that way I do believe like I said that
he probably will change his tune when he
arrives there but let me know what you
guys think what do you think about all
these questions do you think Daenerys
will go mad Queen what did you think was
going on with Jaime when he left Brienne
how little Arya and the Hound do on
their trip to King's Landing and how
bummed are you that CGI is the real
reason that Jon didn't give ghost a
proper send-off when he left Winterfell
let me know in the comments please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already to follow along to the end of
the season that's it for now thanks for
watching I will talk to you soon